Colin Powell lifetime Republican
lifelong Republican retired four-star
general george w bush era secretary of
state has announced that he will be
voting not for the Republican nominee
Donald Trump but rather for the
Democratic presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton in the election that is
now just days away we sort of we're
getting the sense that Colin Powell was
not leaning in the direction of Trump
referring to him as a national disgrace
in some leaked emails a few weeks ago
but yesterday at a lunch in Long Island
Powell gave what many who were in the
room are calling an unreserved
endorsement of his fellow former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
according to Newsday reporter Robert
broadsky saying that she would serve
with distinction and has the experience
to be President also adding about Donald
Trump that he is selling people a bill
of goods is not qualified and insults us
every day I respect Colin Powell here
particularly when he could hold a grudge
against Hillary Clinton for the entire
email scandal issue you might remember
that Hillary Clinton when she was facing
criticism and being investigated for her
use of a private email server said to
the FBI Oh Colin Powell suggested to me
that I use a personal email account and
Colin Powell actually said her people
have been trying to pin it on me the
truth is she was already using the email
server for a year before I Center the
memo about it this is not Colin Powell's
first time voting for a Democrat he did
vote for President Obama in 2008 voted
for president obama for reelection in
2012 in spite of being a quote close
friend of Senator John McCain who's the
Republican candidate back in two
thousand eight and he's even said
negative things about Hillary Clinton in
one of the leaked emails saying quote
everything Hillary touches she kinds of
screws up with hubris and calling her
greedy and not transformational this is
not really that surprising on politics
though if you just look at the party
identification I get it lifelong
Republican Colin Powell voting for
Hillary Clinton but Powell has described
himself as moderate
on social uh on domestic issues he voted
for LBJ in 1964 but over sixty percent
of the country did I've never been a
huge fan of him as an individual but I
found him to be worthy of respect
particularly in 2008 remember this quote
from Colin Powell from 2008 where he
said I'm also troubled by not what
Senator McCain says but but what members
of the party say and it is permitted to
be said such things as quote well you
know that mr. Obama is a Muslim well the
correct answer is he's not a Muslim he's
a Christian he's always been a Christian
but really the right answer is what if
he is is there something wrong with
being a Muslim in this country the
answer's no that's not America is there
something wrong with some seven-year-old
Muslim American kid believing that he or
she could be President uh Colin Powell
he's more of an Eisenhower type
Republican I don't really get why he's
still a Republican I don't feel like
he's changed I think it's the republican
party that has moved way way way to the
right yeah I think it just goes to show
that even though we've moved to the left
on social issues the country at large on
things like health care tax policy has
moved to the right and there really are
no more liberal Republicans left and he
should probably consider changing
parties at this point I agree with that
Rachel there's not really a place for
someone with the total uh package of
colin powell's views in the republican
party yeah i guess and i think a lot of
people also believe that because when he
said that he was supporting obama was
partially for economic reasons and it's
also interesting because he seemed to
borrow language from 2008 that he used
when he was announcing his support of
Obama saying he was transformational and
then when he was giving uh his opinion
of Hillary in the league in elgin and
said she's not transformational so I'm
just wondering was he tired or bored or
lazy or did he just say okay I'm gonna
look back at these comments and just
every range well maybe that's how Colin
Powell evaluates who to vote vote for
right not party but is this going to be
someone that is transformational for the
country the problem with that logic is
Trump would be way more transformational
than Hillary Clinton other than the
identity of Hillary Clinton be
the first female president which has
significant value as I've discussed on
its own but in terms of politics Hillary
Clinton is completely predictable in
many ways it would be a third Barack
Obama term Donald Trump would be hugely
transformational for the country but Pat
in a way that Powell has described as a
national disgrace and I know that that's
something that that for a lot of people
is the reason to stay away from somebody
like Donald Trump uh transformational
yeah that is interesting and I know it
can be confusing I I thinking of an
episode of the newsroom where will
McAvoy the character played by Jeff
Daniels there said I'm a Republican I
only seem liberal because i believe
hurricanes are caused by barometric
pressure and not gay marriage and that
really is i mean it's from from fiction
but it is true that because the
republican party has done so off the
deep end when we hear as as observers of
politics a Republican who seems
reasonable we immediately say that's not
a Republican that should be a Democrat
and I guess it's not true right it's not
he's also said that part of the reason
he is a Republican I don't know how much
I grew this is because he feels like the
party supports the entrepreneurialship
that he really admires uh but it's also
interesting because Mitt Romney attacked
him for his support of Obama which I was
just remembering now saying that it was
on a race thing oh yeah well no anytime
any black person votes for a black
politician it's because of race but of
course the fact that the Republican
Party's white elected officials
overwhelmingly white elected officials
have disproportionately depended on the
white male vote for like a decade a
decade decade after decade that's not a
race thing that's just politics that's
always a nice double standard isn't it
Pat you only see race when it's the non
non standard identity you only see
gender when it's women supporting women
but if a man votes for a male candidate
well just because of the politics yet
seems like you're locked into supporting
a candidate based on your race or your
gender in that case you can't flip and
go the other way I respect Colin Powell
for this and he is making the right
decision obviously